retombée pour jimmy carter la tempête au
moins six morts laurent broomhead nous
promet la neige pour samedi
un monsieur bonsoir les grandes vacances
seront elles dès cette année de moins
grandes vacances c'est bien la question
est posée depuis hier et la réponse
définitive ne saurait tarder elle
intéresse bien sûr tous les enfants qui
ont l'air d'être plutôt contre les
parents plutôt courts et les enseignants
plutôt mitigé et c'est précisément le
président d'une fédération de parents
d'élèves entre lagarde qui a posé le
problème sur la place publique en
déclarant tout net il faut réduire de 15
jours les vacances scolaires 154 jours
scolarisables et une charge de travail
qui répartit sur ce délai aussi court
fait le travail quotidien et le travail
hebdomadaire des élèves est extrêmement
lourd et ne leur permet pas d'avoir une
qualité de vie quotidienne et de madère
en demandant la réduction des vacances
d'été
on le fait pour trois raisons pour cette
une meilleure répartition de cette
charge de travail
deuxièmement pour réduire le fait que
les vacances atténue tout l'acquis du
travail du trimestre précédent et pour
aussi réduire l'inégalité des chances
mais j'ai toujours réfléchit à l'intérêt
que pouvait avoir les enseignants sur ce
problème et il est certain que le
travail quotidien et de madère que font
les enseignants est lourd et fatigante
et qu en répartissant mieux cette charge
il aurait une qualité de vie plus adapté
à la réalité du monde moderne
pensez bien que cette proposition
soulève quantité de problèmes qui
intéressent quantité de profession les
hôteliers les chefs d'entreprise les
responsables de l'étalement des vacances
tout ce qu'ils trouvent beaucoup de
charme aux premiers jours de septembre
est beaucoup trop de chaleur aux
premiers jours de juillet car il faudra
bien faire un choix si l'on veut revenir
à deux mois de vacances est d'abord
disions nous les enseignants les
écoliers français est en vacances ce
week-end compris 210 jours par an contre
155 jours de travail
il est ainsi avec l'italien à la tête de
ses condisciples européen
les jeunes allemands britanniques et
hollandais n'ont eu qu'un mois et demi
de congés d'été et moins de petites
vacances
mais la différence qui a surtout au
rythme de travail on va peu à l'école en
france mais on y travaille beaucoup par
semaine 27 heures dans le primaire et
dans le secondaire 30 à 40 heures
d'activités souvent purement scolaire
par contre nos voisins anglais ou
allemand répartissent effort
intellectuel et sportif activités
d'éveil artistique entre le matin et
l'après midi mais il dispose pour cela
de structure et d'équipements que non
pas nos établissements ce qui explique
une réaction plutôt favorable des
enseignants pour proposition du dr
lagarde met cependant une réaction
prudente nous sommes ouverts à toutes
discussions qui est pour premier
objectif l'intérêt de l'enfant et de ses
rythmes
mais encore une fois il ne nous semble
pas que les moyens réservés à l'accueil
des enfants et à leurs conditions de vie
scolaire familiale et sociale soient
remplies pour que avec une batte
absolument suspecte on en vienne à dire
que dès 1979 telles et telles mesures
doivent être prises
toutes les études ne sont pas encore à
leur terme tant s'en faut
alors pour l'avenir réflexion discussion
oui mais procédure hâtives
sûrement pas le guen cfdt le snes quant
à eux réagissent également dans ce sens
et s'inquiète d'une réduction de la
durée des vacances qui serait décidée
trop vite mais il est certain que
parallèlement à l'intérêt de l'enfant
se pose aussi l'éternelle question de
l'étalement des départs d'été car
l'échelonnement dans les zones scolaires
il est prévu que pour février et passe
alors bien évidemment on attendait la
réponse du seul homme qui pouvait donner
le feu vert christian de lacq le
ministre de l'éducation et bien
christian bilhac qui se refuse à
trancher tout de suite même s'il n'est
pas opposé au principe ce rythme
scolaire n'est probablement pas le
meilleur est à ce point de vue je
retrouve les soucis de monsieur lagarde
je dirai aussi que d'autres fédérations
de parents d'élèves ont le même souci
mais il serait prématuré que je prenne
parti c'est parce que je crois que c'est
important que j'ai demandé au conseil
économique et social à paris et aux
conseils économiques et sociaux de
région de me donner leur avis avec
monsieur soit son ministre de la
jeunesse des loisirs les sports nous
avons saisi ces différents organismes
pour nous donner leur opinion
je vois maintenant revenir sur deux
digestions difficiles sur de pilule bien
amère ingurgiter à quelques jours
d'intervalle les licenciements dans la
sidérurgie plus la réforme de la
sécurité sociale
alors d'abord la sidérurgie après usinor
sacilor aujourd'hui sacilor qui a
annoncé la suppression de six mille huit
cents emplois en un an et demi d'ici à
la fin 81 demain ce sera au tour de
sollac on parle là de 10 700
licenciements réaction les syndicats la
cgt et la cfdt appellent les quelques
135 mille sidérurgiste a exprimé leur
refus la semaine prochaine force
ouvrière demande un plan d'urgence pour
le reclassement des travailleurs tout
comme on le faisait lorsqu'il s'agissait
de calamité agricole
et puis plus ponctuellement les délégués
du personnel d'usinor de l'ain qui ont
donné un pardon qui ont retenu des
représentants de la direction pendant
près d'une heure
et curieusement on ne retrouve pas la
même unanimité pour protester contre le
relèvement des taux de sécurité sociale
annoncée hier par simone veil
la cgt la cfdt et la fen n'ont pu se
mettre d'accord
c'est encore une fois sur la proposition
d'une journée nationale d'action
avancées par la cgt que le désaccord
s'est produit la cfdt je vous le
rappelle considère inefficace ce genre
d'action les réactions syndicales
restent donc disperser la cgt organisera
le 21 décembre jour d'ouverture de la
session spéciale du parlement sur
l'emploi une journée d'action qui
prendra la forme d'arrêts de travail
allant d'une heure à 24 heures avec des
rassemblements et des manifestations
la cfdt demande à ses militants de
déposer immédiatement dans chaque
entreprise
des cahiers de revendications pour
compenser la perte de salaire
entraîné par la hausse des cotisations
force ouvrière revendique également une
compensation salariale tout en
s'alignant tout en soulignant que le
département d'une mesure positive la fen
estime que seuls les salariés vont
supporter directement ou indirectement
le coût de ces nouvelles mesures
en réponse à ces revendications yvon
chotard pour le cnpn a déclaré que les
entreprises serait pas capable
d'accorder des augmentations de salaire
supplémentaire il a estimé à 6 milliards
de francs la charge nouvelle pesant sur
les entreprises
voilà pour que chacun possède bien
toutes les données du problème je crois
qu'il serait souhaitable non pas de
revenir sur les mesures d'hier vous en
avez pris connaissance dans le détail
dans vos journaux mais d'essayer
d'expliquer la situation française dans
le concert des pays comparables aux rats
c'est bien simple les dépenses sociales
elle s'approche partout en europe
ici vous avez une évolution sur cinq ans
dans quatre pays et vous voyez que la la
ligne est ascendante dans tous ces pays
est pratiquement la part des dépenses
sociales dans la production de ces pays
dépasse 1%
elle atteint même 28 % en allemagne le
niveau le plus élevé alors complètement
l'on parle du danemark de l'allemagne
l'allemagne vieux lallali est de la
france
or les deux tiers de ces dépenses celles
qui augmentent plus vite fait
l'assurance maladie et l'assurance
vieillesse
pratiquement tous les pays d'europe
connaissent le même problème ce problème
de financement
mais alors il cherche des solutions mais
leur méthode de financement au départ
sont différentes elles sont pas toujours
les mêmes qui payent alors qu'ils paient
en fait alors en fait je vais vous le
montrer il y a plusieurs solutions soit
l'état soit des cotisations employeurs
ou salariés
alors vous avez des pays comme l'italie
et la france où les cotisations sont les
plus fortes
et c'est notamment les cotisations des
employeurs loyer vous avez un pays par
contre comme le danemark ou c'est l'état
qui plaît le plus c'est dire que c'est
un amour et la peau au danemark est très
progressif il est assez lourd puisqu'il
représente 40% de la valeur de la
production de ce pays
et puis vous avez l'allemagne où ces
chercheurs répartis l'état veut un peu
l'employeur paie un peu et les assurés
peu un peu aussi alors pour l'avenir
maintenant alors effectivement il ya un
problème de financement actuellement
mais pour l'avenir
il risque d'être encore plus grave
l'effet de l'évolution de la population
le risque c'est que la proportion des
personnes qui cotisent deviennent ne se
réduise c'est à dire que le nombre
d'actifs soit plus faible beaucoup plus
faible que celui des inactifs pour peu
jeune pour trop de personnes du
troisième âge disons oui trop peu
d'adultes 10 ans parce que les jeunes
c'est aussi des inédits ce sens et vous
avez par exemple à l'allemagne elle
connaît déjà une situation de ce genre
c'est à dire que trois seuls cinq
salariés paient actuellement des
cotisations pour trois retraités ce qui
rend très difficile le financement des
pensions de vieillesse
alors depuis quelques années ce qui se
passe dans tous les pays d'europe c'est
une baisse de la natalité
on compte que pour nous la population il
faut un taux de fécondité de 2,1 pour de
2,1 c'est à dire que l'on compte toutes
ces qualités c'est le nombre moyen
d'enfants par femme aura tassoto en
france en ce moment non dans tous les
pays d'europe des neuf d'ailleurs le
taux de fécondité est inférieure à ce
niveau il est de 1,41 en allemagne il
est de 1,38 en grande-bretagne 1,86 en
france avec 93 en italie et si la baisse
de la natalité continue la population va
vieillir et les charges sociales que
devront payer les actifs seront plus
lourdes 27 priorité à la famille ce
combat contre la dénatalité a été le
thème central du discours quoi le prix
d'un public a prononcé ce matin lors de
l'inauguration des nouveaux locaux de la
caisse d'allocations familiales à paris
le président rappelait que l'effort
serait d'abord accompli en faveur des
familles d'au moins trois enfants
ceci donc pour enrayer la baisse
dramatique de la fécondité si la baisse
de la fécondité se poursuivaient sur une
longue durée
les conséquences en seraient
irréversibles
une société qui n'est plus capable
d'assurer le remplacement des
générations
et vous savez que nous sommes sur le
point de franchir ce seuil critique
c'est à dire dont l'effectif diminuera
est une société qu'ils se condamnent sa
vitalité est atteinte
car le vieillissement traîne la rigidité
la rigidité des comportements sociaux et
toof l'innovation et paralyse le
dynamisme son économie est affaiblie par
le poids des inactifs
car la population en âge de travailler
ne
peut plus financer les pensions des
retraités
la situation actuelle exige une
réflexion approfondie de tous les
français quelles que soient leur âge
leur métier ou leur opinion politique
l'avenir démographique de notre pays est
au dessus des discussions deux parties
le président a défini trois priorités
pour la politique familiale en 1979
premièrement il faut accentuer l'effort
entrepris en faveur des familles de
moins trois enfants
à compter du 1er juillet 79 l'immense
majorité de ces familles percevra mille
francs de prestations par mois d'autre
part le gouvernement soumettra au
parlement un projet de loi instituant un
revenu minimum familiale de 3500 francs
par mois en faveur des familles de moins
trois enfants
la seconde priorité concerne les mères
de famille en 1979
une étape décisive sera franchie pour
leur assurer une retraite
l'immense majorité des mères de jeunes
enfants sera affilié à l'assurance
vieillesse
la troisième priorité intéressés
familles nombreuses de plus de trois
enfants
le président de la république demande
qu'une aide supplémentaire leur soit
accordé là pour en terminer avec ce
dossier du déficit de la sécurité
sociale dossier que nous avons décidé de
traiter ce soir le plus complètement
possible faut pas négliger l'une des
causes se trouve cause non négligeable
puisque c'est la multiplication de ces
petits travaux clandestins non déclarés
près ce que l'on appelle le travail au
noir
les députés avaient décidé d'y consacrer
une journée d'étude aujourd'hui et nous
à antenne 2 une enquête
cet ouvrier est un travailleur
clandestin
il est en train de rénover un
appartement du sol au plafond à lui seul
il remplace plusieurs artisans plâtriers
peintres maçons serrurier plombier
tapissier etc
officiellement il est électricien dans
une grande société
il a deux enfants et sa femme travaille
le travail au noir vous rapporte combien
vous savez que vous risquiez jusqu'à un
mois de prison et 1000 francs d'amendé
puis je sais mais je crois que même si
j'étais enfin jusqu'à maintenant j'ai
jamais entendu d'y appeler quelqu'un est
dans présent ça se peut qu'ils aient eu
des avants mais enfin je crois pas que
s'arrêterait travail je ne crois pas du
tout quels sont les gens qui vous font
travailler au noir
la plupart habitants des rues de
personnes indiqué comment est-ce qui
vous paie en liquide entendu ça m'évite
de déclarer mes revenus
comme lui ils sont huit cent mille selon
le ministère du travail
la france détient le ruban bleu du
travail noir en europe
les secteurs les plus touchés sont le
bâtiment avec cinq cent mille
clandestins
ensuite le textile la réparation
automobile la coiffure et le
déménagement le travail au noir c'est le
bricoleur qui rend service moyennant
finances mais ce sont aussi et surtout
des entreprises qui emploient des
travailleurs non déclarés la police par
exemple a découvert dans le sentier à
paris sous une trappe
un atelier de confection clandestin ou
des yougoslaves travailler 70 heures par
semaine
au total cette économie parallèle
représente un chiffre d'affaires de 40
milliards de francs pour le gouvernement
c'est trop car il y a des victimes
l'état d'abord qui ne perçoit pas la tva
ni l'impôt sur le revenu la sécurité
sociale ensuite parce que ni le
travailleur clandestin ni son employeur
ne paient les cotisations les artisans
et les entrepreneurs en train qui
souffrent de cette concurrence déloyale
et aujourd'hui avec eux des
parlementaires réagissent
il s'agit certainement pas de rendre la
société française plus policière qu'elle
doit l'être
mais il s'agit peut-être de faire appel
au sens des responsabilités et je dirais
de l'intérêt de chaque français et
chaque français est ce que ça vaut la
peine de faire du travail de voir je
prends le risque de pénaliser d'avoir
une amende de risquer la prison
est ce que ça vaut la peine aussi
n'avoir aucun recours contre ce qu'ils
ont fait une réparation chez vous et si
cette réparation aux un accident avec la
crise et plus d'un million de chômeurs
le travail noire s'est développée ce
n'est pas un paradoxe entre le civisme
et la combine qui permet d'économiser
beaucoup n'hésitent pas une seconde
avant de revenir à la politique
française je voudrais que nous ouvrions
notre chapitre de politique étrangère
avec ce soir 2 4 capitales qui ont
retenu notre attention
peyrens et tel aviv à teyran une petite
surprise d'hier un entretien entre le
chat est l'un des dirigeants de
l'opposition
monsieur st djabi président du front
national qui une fois de plus a refusé
sa collaboration régime
c'est pendant ce temps à ispahan
deuxième ville du pays se dérouler de
très grave incident à l'occasion d'une
manifestation organisée cette fois en
faveur du chat on a pu parler hier
aujourd'hui encore d'une véritable
terreur dans la ville
un souvenir l'iran d'il y a trois jours
avec des milliers de personnes dans les
rues réclamant le départ du shah et ils
se parent et hier dans la seconde ville
du pays les militaires ont dès 5 heures
du matin mise en place montée organisé
une manifestation en faveur du chat
dans un premier temps on a fait venir
des habitants de villages voisins
insuffisant sans doute dans un deuxième
temps on obligera les voiture à
s'arrêter
allumer leurs phares à coller sur les
pare-brise des portraits du champ dans
un troisième temps en fin de journée sur
ceux qui émettent des doutes ou s'y
refuse de crier vive le char l'armée
tire quelques trente morts 300 blessés
dont certains seront achevés à l'entrée
de l'hôpital où ils ont été emmenés
témoignages accablants de médecins
j'opère depuis 20 ans jamais mais man
avait tremblé hier elles ont tremblé
jamais j'avais pleuré hier j'ai pleuré
échec et mat pour sarens le gouvernement
israélien refuse et hier les
propositions faites par l'egypte pour
surmonter les derniers obstacles et la
signature de la paix entre les deux pays
le saut cadettes 2 tu as quitté
jérusalem il y à quelques heures après
une brève escale au caire où nous voyons
il sera de retour demain washington et
rendra compte de l'échec de sa mission à
jimmy carter
face aux pressions de plus en plus vive
des états unis et du président carter
sur israël c'est l'irritation à
jérusalem et la colère des faucons et
des extrémistes qui estime que béguines
à dallas la nuit dernière une grande
manifestation a été organisée sous les
fenêtres de l'hôtel king david à
jérusalem là où résidait l'envoyé
spécial américain monsieur cyrus vance
au milieu de danses et de chants
religieux les slogans étaient israël
n'est pas le cambodge ventes se réveille
toi et rentrer à la maison
les manifestants ont ensuite brûlé un
drapeau américain marchandage pression
de dernière minute ou crise sérieuse
attisée par ces manifestations
d'hostilité on saura dans quelques
heures après cette rencontre sadate
vente au caire la négociation au but
très sérieusement sur un point précis
les étapes qui doivent mener à
l'autonomie de la cisjordanie et de gaza
occupée depuis 1967 par israël comme le
voit on le voit ici cette réunion des
membres du cabinet israélien avec
monsieur 27 emprunte une certaine
lassitude
bien que les israéliens ne semble pas
disposé à aller plus loin
monsieur b dîner renforcé dans sa
position intérieure
en effet même monsieur shimon peres le
chef de l'opposition travailliste très
modérée a critiqué la stricte des
amériques news après ses entretiens avec
monsieur vente monsieur bed-in a précisé
que cette réunion ait permis l'échangé
de vues sérieux mais qu'à la suite des
dernières propositions égyptiennes
transmises par monsieur vente
il apparaissait clairement que les
positions d'israël et de l'egypte
étaient très éloignés donc un jimmy
carter très déçu qui a compris que
vraisemblablement rien ne serait signé
dimanche prochain donc le 17 décembre le
chef de la maison blanche n'a d'ailleurs
pas mâché ses mots un hommage au
président sadate mais le silence sur
menahem begin
la dimension de la crise dans la ville
et ton esprit sont effacées t on peut
redouter que les rapports états unis fra
n en soit considérablement affecté entre
messieurs begin et sadate le président
qu'à faire était passé du rôle de
médiateur a tenu de négociateurs c'est
bien que l'impasse constatée par pour
traiter faire des affaires aux ventes
d'armes et pensé comme un échec
personnel par le président américain et
les prochains mois voire les prochaines
semaines pourrait décider de son avenir
politique
l'iran des négociations avec moscou et
le proche orient sont les grands
dossiers de la maison blanche nous
prépare des relations difficiles avec
les fraises avec une réduction de
crédits américain est bloqué par exemple
par le sénateur byrd remettrait pas en
cause la position et le rôle de
washington au proche orient
il ya une heure nous apprenions que la
france retirerait au début de l'année
prochaine son contingent opérationnel ou
au liban seul restera un détachement
soutien logistique composée d'environ
600 hommes 1 tendances de l'e
communication et j'ai dit et voyez-vous
la paix avec ses rêves ses mirages ses
espoirs
mais ce sera le thème de l'émission que
toute la rédaction d'antenne 2 à
composer pour lundi soir des reportages
de pratiquement tous les pays du monde
la chine l'afrique l'europe et puis des
signatures comme celle de georges
brassens de raymond devos de maurice
béjart de mikis theodorakis et de
vladimir jankelevitch une émission de
l'information d'antenne 2 présenté par
jean-pierre elkabbach lundi soir à 20h30
la politique française maintenant
d'abord il faut savoir que le sénat a
refusé d'inscrire à l'ordre du jour le
texte de l'assemblée européenne
savoir aussi qu'à l'assemblée cette fois
le député pierre bas a annoncé le
lancement d'une pétition nationale sur
l'abolition de la peine de mort savoir
enfin que pour la lettre de l'unité
l'organe quotidien du parti socialiste
le débat d'hier des bâtisses poursuivra
mercredi prochain ne porte pas sur des
rivalités de personnes mitterand moroy
rocard mais sur des points fondamentaux
qui touche l'union de la gauche et
monsieur mitterrand précisément vient de
faire savoir qu'il souhaite une réunion
du comité de liaison des trois partis de
gauche pour protester contre la
politique du gouvernement en matière
sociale du côté de la majorité
maintenant il ne faut plus parler de
remous mais
de bouillonnement au sein du rpr le
ministre alain peyrefitte vient en effet
d'écrire aux députés son mouvement une
lettre très sévère à propos de jacques
chirac
le garde des sceaux s'inquiète des
récentes décisions du président du rpr
il se demande même s'ils n'ont pas été
prises par certains personnages occultes
qui semble s'être emparée de l'appareil
gaulliste je cite là monsieur alain
peyrefitte qui demande en conclusion aux
députés de réfléchir avant de donner
suite aux initiatives de jacques chirac
pourtant ce matin le président du rpr
dans une interview à l afp avait répété
qu'il ne voulait pas sortir de la
majorité car cela remettrait en cause le
choix société qui l'a fait en mars
dernier michel debré en revanche n'a pas
l'air d'être effrayé par paris nice je
considère que cette élection au suffrage
universel de l'assemblée européenne a
été préparée j'ose le dire en dépit du
bon sens avec une extrême légèreté et
que tout ce qui compte pour la france
c'est à dire son économie son
indépendance à défense risque d'être
remise en cause
dans ces conditions je reprends ma
liberté de parole
et puis ma liberté d'action on verra
bien mais je ne peux pas être solidaire
d'une orientation politique dont en mon
âme et conscience je considère qu'elle
est mauvaise pour la france enfin une
période raymond barre dans le matin de
demain le premier ministre repousse
l'hypothèse d'une collaboration avec les
socialistes
il y a une toute petite heure une demi
heure même nous apprenions qu'un interne
de l'hôpital de creil venait d'être
écroué pour avoir infligé des sévices
sur un malade et pour avoir refusé avec
un autre interne également inculpé mais
laissé en liberté celui là
d'hospitaliser ce malade et qui était
victime d'une hémorragie du cervelet
l'actualité sportive ce qui d'abord avec
la revanche du suédois ingemar stenmark
qui a remporté le slalom parallèle
mme hadad madonna di campiglio alors ces
vendeuses italien c'est normal au
lendemain de son échec dans son spécial
le suédois a écrasé tous ses rivaux
une épreuve qui pourtant n'a aucune
incidence sur le classement individuel
de la coupe du monde en boxe championnat
d'europe des super plumes hier soir un
près de charny tally il feignait un
réseau lee a conservé son titre en
faisant match nul en 12 reprises avec
son challenger le français jo riez petit
mais de l'avis de tous les spécialistes
français ou non jurietti mérité le titre
avec au moins deux poêles avance
hippisme enfin avec le tiercé disputé à
vincennes dans la 5e course la
combinaison gagnante
le 15 le 10 et le 14 qui va rapporter je
pense que vous allez le voir si vous ne
vous voyez pas je vais vous le dire dans
l'ordre plus de 18 mille francs d 8627
francs 50 et dans un ordre différent
2500 francs 50
le docteur andrivet ainsi que plusieurs
médecins de l'institut national
supérieur de l'éducation physique
pourrait être mise à la disposition du
mise à la santé les raisons de ce départ
officieux sont encore obscures mais le
docteur andrivet ancien médecin chef de
l'institut des sports s'est occupée des
muscles la préparation de nombreux
athlètes pendant très longtemps
et puis surtout suspension pour un an
d'alain estève le deuxième ligne
international de béziers motif de cette
mise à l'écart très sévère donc
agressions répétées et puis fourchette
dans les yeux de l'adversaire tornade
tempête se rafales de vent mer fort
tourments tel est le lot depuis 24
heures des côtes du nord est également
de tout l'ouest de la bretagne
tout l'été les rames sont très nombreux
le plus pas la plupart du temps ce sont
des drames de détresse qui ne sont pas
revenues dans la matinée et puis voici
les images qui nous parviennent de règne
dix hommes d'équipage du chalutier
lorientais l'action disparus en mer les
recherches sont restées vaines
dans l'estuaire de la gironde la
navigation est interdite et les qu'eads
petit port breton sont parfois submergés
par les vagues à saint guénolé un dock
flottant de 15 mille tonnes s'est échoué
sur la côte à terre les bourrasques de
vent la grêle sont les causes
d'accidents et de collisions qui ont
fait cinq morts en bretagne pays de
loire 150 peupliers sont arrachés par le
vent dans le maine et loire une tornade
en mayenne provoque la mort d'un homme
soufflant une cinquantaine de toiture
les vents d'ouest et de sud ouest
soufflent à 130 kilomètres heure à la
pointe du finistère et dans le choletais
une centaine de maisons ont été
endommagées près de tours enfin le vent
a couché sur la chaussée
un camion de 10 tonnes voilà un bon
maître vous êtes là comme ça le jeudi
alors est-ce que ça va continue d'abord
se vend cette tempête
oui encore du vent mais un vin qui va
tourner annonçant un refroidissement je
m'explique qu'il y avait au dessus de
l'atlantique la semaine dernière un
grand tourbillon de nuages qui tournait
comme ça lance en ce contrat de celui
des aiguilles d'une ont regardé l'air
est inspiré du sud c'était de l'air doux
et puis le tourbillon les cyclones est
venu au dessus de l'islande au dessus de
l'irlande par dont il s'est rapproché
donc de la france d'où la tempête que
nous avons connus historique d'ailleurs
et cette fois l'air vient de l'ouest de
l'air plus froid
et puis s'il continue sa route cette
fois à l'air à venir du nord de l'air
arctique et la pluie va se transformer
en neige
alors regardons la carte de demain la
carte de demain des nuages à peu près
sur toute la france avec des pluies
quelques petites éclaircies et puis
surtout de la neige au dessus de 1000
mètres d'altitude
c'est à dire sur les massifs des vents
encore assez fort à l'intérieur fort
près des côtes avec des rafales d'abord
des vents du sud-ouest fille qui tourne
rond au nord-ouest
enfin samedi ses vents seront
pratiquement du nord c'est dire qu'il
fera plus froid
et si la carte est à peu près la même la
neige tombera cette fois au dessus de
500m et même on peut le dire dans le
nord du pays
et si ça continue et bien les jours
celui suivants selon la logique seront
encore plus froid fixant la neige
la température devrait descendre environ
de 10 degrés en quelques jours comme je
rectifie quelque chose cependant je vous
parlais du tiercé
il était inscrit que c'était le 15 le 12
et le 14 c'est parfait que 15 de 10 et
le 14 donc il fallait me croirez pas ce
qui était écrit dernier rendez-vous avec
l'actualité ce soir le dernier journal
avec pierre-alain vers 23h15 mais pour
terminer ce journal pour essayer de nous
évader un petit peu des préoccupations
de la journée et vous avez vu qu'elle
était sévère propose du rythme et des
couleurs sur la scène du théâtre des
champs-elysées où la compagnie brasil
tropicale répète son nouveau spectacle
une avant première sur antenne 2 en leur
compagnie vous souhaite une excellente
fin de soirée à tous à 2
marc antoine
c'est
m
bravo
réponse en a pas beaucoup
je n'ai que deux
c'est
le chien